all these false stories i mean this kid
comes from a family with family members
of multiple races
they did a deep dive on all of his
social media i mean they did a
colonoscopic
kind of review of his social media and
they found no connections of
any form of racism of any kind no
connections to militia of any kind
no connections to anybody like that of
any kind no statements like that
at any time all they had was that he had
once gone to a trump rally
that was their sole basis the oh you
went he went to a trump rally like
exactly and he's a a gun supporter and
he's a a police military supporter
and that was it but they all they just
did that most of the media ran with
these false allegations the stream of
false
to this day they continue to tell false
stories the prosecutors continue to lie
about them
using court proceedings to get away with
the lie the kid's the most innocent
defendant i've ever represented
ever been involved with but the case
goes far past him if he gets convicted
self-defense is dead in america
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
trial lawyer
and an all-star political gambler also a
primo promoter
of locals.com robert barnes welcome back
to the reuben report
glad to be here i am glad to have you
man i didn't realize until literally two
minutes ago that
we have not spoken uh in a one-on-one
forum
for over two years um
is the world getting better or worse in
those two years well you know back then
i was taking a lot of controversial
cases so it was you know alex we were
talking about alex jones the covington
kids wesley snipes ralph nader girls
gone wild all
the rest of it so i decided to take less
controversial cases so i took
donald trump during the elections uh amy
cooper in new york
kyle rittenhouse self defense but yeah
the world just keeps getting crazier
particularly from a legal political
perspective
yeah so what put you on the map is it
fair to say that what originally sort of
put you on the map in a bigger sense
was the bet on trump is that really the
thing that kind of got you out there as
more of a public lawyer
yeah yeah i mean basically i'd always
been done a lot of tax work
but for a lot of reasons i didn't need
that to be high profile
and had done a lot of civil rights work
but had not made myself a public figure
but people had followed the trump bet
because it was a big bet and the rest he
became a public figure and during the
trump time period it became more
important
to be a public figure defending certain
issues in the court of public opinion
yeah and now you're an all-star youtuber
who hangs out like this all day
like world world come at me so i want to
get into some of those cases that that
you've covered obviously but let's start
with
with trump's current lawsuit because
just in the last you know 10 days or so
he has announced that
he's basically going after big tech in a
class action lawsuit and not just big
tech but actually some of the heads
of these companies so can you give
people the 101
the sort of must-have info on what the
lawsuit actually is and then we'll
talk about the chances of it succeeding
sure so basically trump has brought a
claim
saying that all the big tech giants
conspired with
various government actors to kick him
off of and exclude him
from all of their platforms and he is
saying that they did so as state actors
and thus are subject to first amendment
limitations so that's the core of his
claim against google
against facebook and against twitter as
well as dorsey zuckerberg
and the google ceo individually so the
key there seems to be some kind of
collusion with the government he's not
arguing
just that twitter facebook and instagram
all sat down and maybe he did something
but somehow there was a connection to
the government
do you have any idea if there's evidence
of that or
or what he could actually prove that
would show it
i think you they made an amended
complaint make better allegations
factually
but there is inferential evidence that
fauci
pelosi and harris had specifically
requested
each of those platforms to remove trump
from those platforms some of that's
based on some of their public statements
some of that's based on some of the
emails that came out from the foyer
request with fouchy and zuckerberg
there's much more collusion some of that
is indirectly referenced by robert
kennedy's suit against facebook pending
in california
about the same set of allegations so i
think if they make better allegations
they may be able to get to the discovery
stage and find out
just how much these big tech giants were
operating at the direct request
of government actors right so before we
get to discovery which obviously is the
interesting part of this
why is he doing it as a class action and
not just him going after them for how he
was
you know in his in his eyes uh you know
basically
wronged i think his purpose in this his
heart is in the right place
i think some of the lawyers involved
might not have the technical skill to
translate that well
because there could have been a class
action alleging that big tech is really
part of the public digital square
and the public square has just moved
from the physical world to the digital
world
and from the geographic world to the
online world and he would have had i
think a strong claim on that at least to
challenge existing law and to extend it
they didn't really do that so this
particular class action
isn't the strongest because what he's
alleging really is that he was targeted
because he was president trump
and he's trying to bring all these other
people in that have been targeted for
political reasons
but they're not president trump so from
a pure legal perspective technically
it's not the best claim
right so can you explain like kind of
just how the process works so he now
brings this class action
and how does it get to the judge and
like
is it one judge that will decide if this
thing can go to trial effectively here's
what's likely to happen
they'll likely try to move to transfer
it from the southern district to florida
where he filed it to the northern
district of california
on grounds that it's a term of service
dispute at least twitter
probably facebook and youtube will try
that as well that he'll that would be
his favorite
meaning you get it meaning you get it to
cali because that's where they're based
exactly yeah and if they and they have
some contractual language that
can depending on the nature of the claim
uh require that
if they say so they they're gonna want a
different district court judge assigned
and a different court of appeals they'll
want the ninth circuit not the 11th
circuit
they'll also want any slap law to apply
which doesn't apply in florida but it
would apply in california
because that would make trump
responsible for the other side's legal
fees
if he loses so that would be his first
big battle the second battle will be a
motion to dismiss before it ever gets to
class certification stage
if he wins at that level then he gets
discovery
and then after that a single judge
usually decides whether or not there's
class certification
so he's got several procedural hurdles
to get through first right so who
decides that part because it seems to me
that this thing
even if trump doesn't win if it at least
gets to discovery
we're gonna find out something you know
if twitter and facebook and youtube have
to open up the books
and really show oh members of congress
or the senate
were or the administration were actually
dming people about you know coordinating
some of this stuff or whatever else it's
showing related to
manipulating algorithms or shadow
banning or anything else it's like
that's the win even if it's not a legal
win so
how do we at least get there he
basically needs to enhance the complaint
so i think he should add some lawyers to
the team like alan dershowitz like
harmeet dillon
harmony dillon is a very good state
action twitter claim currently pending
so add some lawyers who are familiar
with this space
uh and change his complaint his cl
complaint as it currently exists
won't get him past a motion to dismiss
but if they add to it i think he has
good grounds to allege
that these these individual actors were
acting at the direct request
of vice president kamala harris and of
speaker of the house nancy pelosi and
maybe of anthony
fauci in other contexts and then i think
you can get to discovery and you're
absolutely right
there's going to be a lot of revelatory
discovery
if he can get to that stage so i hope he
improves the case
so that he can get to that stage i i
sense you think maybe he doesn't have
the best legal representatives around
him right now the way you're describing
it
uh no that it's one of these groups
that's a dc based group that their roots
are in sort of big oil corporate
lobbying
so they're you know if you wanted a
regulatory issue on on energy
they're fantastic first amendment
constitutional issue on big tech that's
not the area of focal point
so i think the these lawyers are lawyers
that are unfamiliar with this space and
it showed up in the suit
and right now those of us that are
familiar in this space that want this
lawsuit to move forward
are very concerned that as alleged this
lawsuit is as doa
so he can improve it though he's got
plenty of times to amend it
but with trump sometimes his personnel
picks gary a little hit or miss
right did you think about picking up the
phone and saying hey guys i know a
little something about this we have some
connections here
actually a bunch of us did and it's just
uh trump is trump
so you know he makes his decisions at
different times like
uh you know the i've been telling him
ever since actually november that uh
he should be on locals i mean if you
want to compete with uh
all the big tech people what better way
to monetize trump's brand
well i mean there's so many different
ways he could do this but he has a lot
of other people whispering in his ear
and i think some of the people that are
whispered in his ear don't really want
him to succeed in his suit
so i think that and it was a problem
throughout his four years that there was
some you know an angel on one side on
one shoulder a devil on the other
and he doesn't always get the best
advice but people are telling him that
now so
i hope he takes corrective action before
the case can get dismissed
for the record i know you're not the
only person in somewhat of the inner
circle that has mentioned locals him and
the truth is
although it would cause us some
headaches obviously and some
you know there would be some legal
issues and technical stuff and all of
that he of course is welcome on there
and i honestly think the guy could make
probably 250 million a month
on the idea that 50 million people would
give him probably five bucks
to be part of that community it's like
it's bananas but
he's the best it's the best way to take
out big tech
the best way to really take out big tech
is to replace big tech
and and and i think i think his heart is
absolutely in the right place in
bringing the suit credit to him for
doing so
it doesn't translate as well legally but
it's another place where he could
uh mount a better challenge if he's also
supporting
independent tech platforms that are the
real threat to big tech long term
where i know we've discussed this a
little bit but i'm curious in the last
two years if you've shifted at all
where are you on in terms of regulation
or breaking them up
or nothing or something that i'm not
mentioning
interestingly enough senator rubio has
put it was a bill i proposed to senator
hawley three years ago
rubio is now put forward which is makes
it simple if big
tech wants section 230 immunity it was
if you're a monopoly
if you have more than 80 market share in
your space
then you have to honor first amendment
limitations like
locals does voluntarily if you honor
first amendment limitations
then you get section 230 immunity but if
you don't honor sex
first amendment limitations and you
decide to censor for political purposes
then you don't get section 230 immunity
that to me that carrot and stick
approach gets around the government
regulation problem
and gets around them getting to do
whatever they want problem it says you
want a special
we'll give you the care to special
immunity but it comes with a stick that
you have to honor the first amendment
once you acquire certain economic
influence within the marketplace
are you worried though if they got rid
of those protections the 230 protections
that in essence they would have to
basically have a team of lawyers that
would be watching what
everyone says all day long knowing that
at any given moment you know someone
puts child pornography on there or some
other you know a terrorist threat or
something
that bam they could just be sued into
oblivion and gone that day
yeah that's why i'm not in favor of just
scratching section 230.
my view and i'm not in favor of the
government regulating i get why people
like the idea of public utilities et
cetera
but look at any history of the
government regulating anything and see
where that turns out net positive
so that's why my view is give them stay
within the private marketplace
incentives but just change the
incentives to say we're going to give
you a special benefit nobody else gets
total immunity from suit for anything
set on your platform but
you just have to honor the first
amendment and how you regulate that
platform
once you have more than 80 market share
in your area of the public square
do you think it's possible that at this
point we're like the ship has just
sailed on all of this that
big tech is now so big so ubiquitous
our government is so dysfunctional it's
controlled by an awful lot of people
that guys like you and i don't like
that the idea that they could actually
do anything not only make the decision
but then carry the decision through
is just like it's just bananas at this
point i think they stole the capacity
for it because they show it
the quickness with which they got rid of
trump was a reminder that they can
invent ai that's first amendment
oriented ai
to regulate their own platforms so they
have the competition that's what's also
great about locals reason
why i promote it is local shows you can
have a platform that you
is first amendment compliant that is uh
technologically capable of delivering on
that first amendment compliant
tech platform and so all they if they
have problems with it they can look to
locals as the example and just borrow
that
and implement it so they clearly have
the capacity to do it
i got to get you on payroll man but you
know the the truth is that the way we've
dealt with
it so far i mean first off because you
have a paywall as you know just a couple
bucks you can it's as little as two
dollars
that cleans up 99.9 of everything so we
have no problem with bots
and trolls and and truly hateful people
it just doesn't exist
but as i always say to people it's like
man if you're going to
come on and do something illegal you got
a much bigger problem than me or locals
there's there's laws that exist so
you're gonna have the government coming
after you you're not gonna worry about
what dave rubin's gonna do
precisely and that's it what it shows is
the capacity local shows all the ability
of what would a first amendment
supporting tech platform
look like without the stalking without
the harassment without the obscenity
without unnecessary trolling you can
have both the best of both worlds
and locals proves it and that's where i
think we can use locals as an example
not only as an exit ramp from big tech
monopoly but also as a legal example to
say this is what big tech
should have to emulate if they want to
continue to get special immunity under
the law
i heard alan dershowitz talking about
this case and he did say some of the
things that you just said there that
maybe it isn't quite as tight as written
as it should be
but he said that this might be the most
important first amendment case in modern
times
do you agree with that oh i agree
entirely that's why he
i and others want to see the suit be
brought in the best most effective way
add claims for unjust enrichment because
all these companies got rich off of
trump
then after they got rich off of trump
decided they could politically censor
him
ad claims for consumer fraud because all
of them lied to people
jack dorsey famously i'm going to be the
free speech wing of the free speech
party
i just want jack dorsey to have to keep
his promises
and so that's where and the reason why i
think dershowitz is out there is
he's trying to get with trump you have
to talk to him through the tv cameras
god bless him he'll listen to you on the
phone but he listens better when it's
through the tv camera
so uh that i if durschwitz is giving
great advice it's absolutely one of the
most essential critical cases
for the future of the country because
either we're going to have free speech
or we're not
and if private companies own the public
square and it keeps going the way it's
going free speech will be dead in
america
so basically you're saying dealing with
trump as a client is completely the
reverse of how
you would do it normally where you want
those off the record conversations trump
you got to go on youtube or on tv to
tell him what you're thinking
precisely that's the best way he listens
it's he's a unique mindset
yeah so what else sort of legally we'll
get into some of the cultural stuff
in a moment but what else kind of
legally is on your docket right now that
you're putting your energy into
so uh the combination of efforts so one
is in terms of the entire election
context
from representing the president during
the campaign right after the campaign
there's a lot of those issues that need
to be reinforced a lot of states are
passing good laws
helping states pass those laws following
up on the audits that are taking place
because if we don't have confidence in
our election integrity the entire
democracy crumbles overnight
so yeah can you just real quick on that
so obviously
even talking about this i could be blown
off youtube in in just a second but
fortunately i am on local so it's all
right
so what happened to all of those
lawsuits because there seemed to be hope
there were people that
that i trusted that i i feel like are
sound legal minds that felt there was
some movement there
and then everything just sort of
crumbled at once so what actually
happened
i and a group of lawyers were that close
to getting to run all the lawsuits
and our focus was that the lawsuits were
going to be based on the election not
being run in a constitutionally
conforming manner
that there were votes counted that were
not either by someone who was not
constitutionally qualified to vote
because of age or some other issue or
because they didn't live at the location
et cetera
or the ballot was cast in a manner that
wasn't a constitutionally qualified
manner
it wasn't it wasn't the signat the
signature match check didn't conform on
an absentee ballot
as an example and the ballots were not
counted and
uh canvassed in a constitutionally
qualified manner
that conforms to international election
standards and the united states election
commission standards we had established
all of these claims we were building
these suits in all of these states
it was the ultimate georgia recount case
that the president filed
but the what happened is it got hijacked
midway through
by people who got distracted by some
shiny objects
and people who like lynnwood sydney
powell god bless him rudy giuliani
they had no election law background and
but they felt confident that their
sources were giving them accurate
information
we were telling them no it's not
accurate information it's a red herring
that's going to basically tar and
feather the legitimate claims
uh and that's what happened
unfortunately and the president he knew
giuliani way back she was like hey this
is the guy who bust up the mob i'll just
go with that guy
and some of us were telling him that's
not rudy's thing anymore
exactly he hasn't been in court since
1992. uh
and unfortunately that's what happened
and so like there's hearings
going on about sanctions issues etc they
got distracted by the shiny object i
always say every great crime
needs a great patsy and they fell for
the great patsy
rather than looking but that didn't mean
there was no crime
there were a lot of constitutional
issues with the election that
unfortunately the supreme court
ultimately didn't take up i think in
part because these other claims were so
outlandish
that it made a lot of judges say i don't
want to get anywhere near this so in
essence if sydney powell or linwood or
some of those guys had not been sort of
running around with the more outlandish
stuff like
you know dominion voting machines
related to venezuela and it's a plan
that's been going off
if they had not run with that you think
that there was enough
stuff to at least get cases that would
have been heard instead of just they
threw everything out
basically exactly i mean we were that
close to getting the georgia secretary
of state
to voluntarily give us a whole bunch of
stuff and the moment linwood did his
press conference
where he said a lot of crazy stuff and
then sydney followed up with her stuff
he was like oh i'm not getting anywhere
near this that somehow
the whole court system and the legal
class and even a bunch of congressmen
were like okay you're asking me to
associate with allegations of the ghost
of chavez and
china and iran and their secret servers
in germany and
and i kept telling everybody on that
side of the aisles like even if you
believe that
no one else is going to believe that so
let's focus on our good claims
not get to the wild claims but the wild
claim sucked up all the energy in the
room and
killed it right and the thing that was
so crazy about it was not
just all of the claims and everything
else but then for those of us that try
to analyze this stuff honestly i kept
saying all along i said look
if if sidney powell who has a pretty
good track record if she's
just self-immolating right now if she's
just making crazy stuff up and gonna
pour gasoline arsenal burn up
well then at the end we'll know that and
in a weird way i suppose that
that is what happened so here we are
here we are exactly but in the process
people overlooked
the fact that there were a bunch of
people who voted who don't appear to
have been
qualified to vote and what anybody
constitutionally qualified is that the
constitution gives to the state
legislatures
exclusive control over the entire voting
process for the presidency
and the state legislature said these
people couldn't vote and yet a lot of
peace states allowed them to vote
they said they couldn't vote by this
method and they i'll give an example
arizona they just did a small signature
match check
it came back that 30 times more
signatures didn't match according to the
democrats own expert
then was the margin of victory in
arizona if we had got signature match
checks when i talked to the president
right
right out of the gate i said if they'll
give you signature match checks
the election is on the up and up if they
won't that means they're scared
that there there's problems no state
would allow a signature match check to
occur
so what was their argument for not
allowing it was it simply just like
we're the democrats and we got what we
wanted so
originally they didn't have good
arguments and then their arguments
became sidney powell's allegations
they're like we're not going to dignify
these crazy claims and so forth so they
use
that as their best cover their best fig
leaf because i'll give an example the
georgia secretary of state
promised back in 2018 when he digitized
all the ballots with the
contract with dominion he said what's
great about this is we'll now print
ballots to the entire world we can
publish
every ballot to the whole world and
everybody can see how clean the election
is
so one of the first things i asked him
when i came down for the president was
why don't
let's go ahead and do that he's like
i'll get back to that he never got
around to it
which means there's something in those
ballots that's unusual there's something
in those ballots that will lead people
to say
why does it look that way why does it
why does it have this problem and i
can't
tell you what some of them are some of
them from the ballots we saw there were
people who were writing in names and
signing in ways that were completely
contradictory so you could look at him
and say that's probably not the same
person
and unfortunately those really good
claims got swamped out by the bad claims
so do you think that the states like
arizona that's doing some audit stuff
now and and georgia now is trying to
pass some laws that everyone of course
is saying are racist and everything's
like are any of these laws to tighten up
the
the roles show ids basic things that are
being called tools of white supremacy
do you think this stuff can work oh
absolutely so there's lots of
these they we've identified a wide range
of weaknesses in the system
that were exploited in 2020 that are now
getting corrected in most states in the
country not all states california's
going more crazy
but every place else for the most part
is actually tightening down the laws
especially in these key swing states
wisconsin acknowledge that they're not
going to allow the same thing to happen
again
michigan is saying they're not going to
allow the same thing georgia arizona
pennsylvania's about to do an audit
and what we're and i am for all audits
is why i tell my friends on the left
we should always have audits so
everybody has confidence in the election
outcome
this isn't about right or left this is
about having confidence that the
election was done on the up and up
and what better way to do so than a
transparent audit you know the
it's uh what i told people throughout
was when the state kept saying don't
worry everything's fine
that's like asking bernie madoff have
you taken a look at your books and
bernie came back and said yeah
my books are still good that's not the
way we do it we give an audit and that's
the way we should do it
you mean you don't let the guy audit
himself is that that's not how it works
precisely
you don't let the people accused of
doing something wrong be the ones to
tell you no don't worry everything's
cool
so how is this what we're talking about
right now sort of directly related to
the trump lawsuit because obviously as
you know
there's there's a slight chance that
youtube won't let us post this that
you're saying right now right like
that we know that that is a possibility
that could be directly related to
trump's lawsuit right
absolutely one of the uh what a bunch of
us are telling trump's team to add to
the lawsuit
is to add two components on the election
aspect one is add all the hunter biden
stuff
that all the suppression of hunter biden
that was big tech censorship
at the request of a political party and
arguably state actors
you know go i think they'll fight that
one seems like the more obvious one that
clearly they couldn't have just decide
everyone at once we no
you can't talk about the laptop and
we're not going to let the new york post
print journalism arguably the biggest
cover-up of a presidential election
political scandal
in american history and so i would have
included that
i would have included it as a lot of
this were really illicit in kind
campaign contributions
then you tie in the election aspect
because a lot of these election rule
changes
were being funded by mark zuckerberg he
was
privately fi fund uh financing various
clerks
election clerks to change the rules
throughout the country
so why not add that to the lawsuit
because then you have a robust lawsuit
that gets to all of these scandals
that entitles you to a wider range of
discovery gives you a better argument to
get past motions to dismiss
and i think the president would be
legally entitled to bring all of them so
is he
he's personally suing these guys too
like he's personally suing zuckerberg
how does that even
become part of this what could have been
the suit right now the way it's drafted
it's highly likely that those claims
will be dismissed i think what trump was
thinking about where they could amend
the complaint to properly allege it
is that the way he saw this is this
didn't go from state actor
direct to big tech and then to
zuckerberg it went from
state actor to zuckerberg to facebook
so he's not suing zuckerberg if he does
it right he's not suing zuckerberg
because of what facebook did
for which zuckerberg could not be
individually sued under the corporate
veil
but he's suing him because zuckerberg
was using his power over facebook
at the request of the state to control
the public dialogue and manipulate the
outcomes of the election
is part of the problem here that we know
that people can lie to congress and
nothing happens you know the famous
james clapper scratching the top of his
head you know we do not wittingly
spy on the american people flat out lie
and now he's a cnn
contributor or jack dorsey at twitter
you know basically telling ted cruz we
don't
shadow man and it's like you obviously
do
but of course i know with the word like
shadowban it doesn't have like a
technical definition
so he can probably wiggle out of it that
way but the point is that you can lie
to congress now and it just doesn't
matter yeah unless you're roger stone
yeah you know unless you're the wrong
political party right then maybe the law
will matter suddenly
but absolutely that that's the the uh
bifurcated
uh two-tiered system of justice that the
department of justice has
accelerated in the trump era is one of
the greatest risks and threats
to justice and its integrity and the
perception of
integrity amongst the broader public
yeah all right so
election trump okay maybe my youtube
channel's here maybe not either way i'll
be just fine thanks to locals
uh what else is on your mind right now
on the legal front
well i think the biggest issue that
biggest case that i have coming up
is going to be the kyle rittenhouse case
because this is the right of
self-defense which to me the second
amendment is not so much about guns
it's about the right of self-defense the
most effective means of self-defense is
to have
access to the method of self-defense
being a gun ownership
but what the second amendment's really
about is your right to defend yourself
against either the state or other
citizens in order to secure your
property and your liberty
and the there's probably no more pure
act of self-defense than what kyle
rittenhouse did
and the fact they're trying to put him
in prison for life
is one of the greatest risks and threats
to self-defense in american legal
history
and that trial is coming up this
november and it was being cheered on
by the mainstream media as if he was a
white supremacist of course
there's no evidence that he's a white
supremacist but could you just back up
and
i showed the video on the show but for
people that don't really remember the
case this was in kenosha
can you just explain to people what
happened and actually what he's charged
with
sure so you know kyle rittenhouse is a
son of a working class
nurse uh single mom uh who
to give you an idea of who he is he goes
back he went back and forth when he was
young
to wanting to do some sort of military
or police work or be a nurse
he's a guy who sees himself as a
protector as someone who rushes into a
traumatic situation
and tries to heal the situation so
that's who he is by personality that's
who he is by biography
and that's by the way what he said in
videos that day right before that that's
why he was there he was not there to
hunt anyone down or shoot anybody he was
there to help
meaning if people were being assaulted
yeah completely and while people saw the
gunning that he had for self-defense and
for the defense of property and others
what he also had on him was a bunch of
nursing equipment and nursing materials
to help people so what happened in
kenosha was after there was sort of a
misrepresentation of what happened in
the blake case
where they thought the police officer
did something different than what was
actually the case as it ultimately
turned out
so it was one of those sort of fake blm
narratives that all of a sudden they
started having riots they started
burning down the city kenosha's a
working-class town on the border of
of illinois and was in between milwaukee
and illinois
uh they were burning down businesses and
what people a lot of people don't know
is most businesses don't have arson
insurance or particularly riot insurance
riots often an exception under their
insurance policies so these were
businesses that were small businesses
that were wiped out forever
no means of recompense and this was
happening day
after day night after night the governor
was letting the democratic governor was
letting it happen frankly
not calling in the national guard so a
bunch of local people in the community
went out that night and said let's
protect people and what kyle did was
let's protect people and i'm going to be
able to try to help people who get hurt
and so he goes out there and that night
the first person that there's a
he gets different attacks on him and
finally he gets this one guy who chases
him down
throwing things at him people from
firing guns behind him
there's video of all of this by the way
all of it exactly grabs the gun
tries to pull the gun away from him he
ends up getting shot by the way this guy
was suicidal
he he was he had been previously
convicted of a bunch of horrendous
crimes
he had tried to kill himself repeatedly
just been let out of a mental
institution so that was the mindset of
this individual who attacked him
and he put things into motion i think if
that guy had got that gun that night
there'd be a lot of other people dead
because he's got a mass shooter kind of
psychology
so uh so kyle probably saved a lot of
other people's lives that night just by
defending himself in that situation
then kyle's trying to run away trying to
run towards police
when he gets chased by more people he
gets thrown to the ground
people attack him with a skateboard
another person comes at him with a gun
one person he shoots that dies one
person he shoots gets harmed
but in both cases they're grabbing his
gun trying to pull it away from him
while one person is trying to shoot him
another person is trying to hit him
so after that happens he's still in
shock he runs towards the police
gives himself up they tell him to go
home and then he gets charged with
multiple counts of intentional homicide
and attempted intentional homicide
where they're trying to put him in
prison for life even though everybody
including the new york times who broke
down the video said
this is one of the cleanest clearest
cases of self-defense they've ever
seen i i actually missed that from the
new york times because most of the media
that i saw was just on
this kid's a white supremacist i mean
that's what it was he was a white
supremacist
in essence hunting down black people
even though it's all on video
all these false stories i mean this kid
comes from a family with family members
of multiple races
they did a deep dive on all of his
social media i mean they did a
colonoscopic
kind of review of his social media and
they found no connections of any form of
racism of any kind
no connections to militia of any kind no
connections to anybody like that of any
kind
no statements like that at any time all
they had was that he had once gone to a
trump rally
that was their sole basis the oh he went
he went to a trump rally like
exactly and he's a a gun supporter and
he's a
police military supporter and that was
it but they all they just did the most
the media ran with these false
allegations the
stream of false to this day they
continued to tell false stories
the prosecutors continue to lie about
them using court
proceedings to get away with the lie the
kid's the most innocent defendant i've
ever represented ever been involved with
but the case goes far past him if he
gets convicted
uh self-defense is dead in america so
how worried are you in general
that the reality and the evidence of
cases like this
actually don't matter anymore and what
really matters is public opinion or
pressure put on by the mayor
or we saw you know that the city of
minneapolis paid out
i think it was 26 million dollars if i'm
not mistaken to george floyd's family
before
the verdict of the trial that that
really like the theater has far more to
do
with with what happens than the reality
of the case
what i've been uh taught what i teach a
lot of young lawyers is the court of
public opinion often matters a lot more
than the court of law
that you can lose a case in the court of
public opinion before you can ever
win it in the court of law and that was
what's critical in kyle's case
it was critical to to get all these
false there's a reason why prosecutors
keep lying about him in court over and
over again
it's because they know that those lies
will be repeated by the media
which will get back to the jury pool and
the judges and the politicians
which will all have some role in how
kyle's case is done
that's what you have to defend the u.s
supreme court said 40 years ago
a competent lawyer must defend his
client in the court of public opinion
and to actually be an effective
representative of his
of his client that's why the court of
public opinion is critical and that's
where a lot of people who think they may
be powerless
don't underestimate their own power
their participation in the court of
public opinion
ultimately shapes the outcome of these
cases when you talk to some of the
prosecutors like
off the record if you're having a
whiskey with one of these guys after i
mean do they realize how evil what
they're doing is or they just believe
it's just it's just part of the process
for some of them they actually believe
in it they're politically ambitious
politically aspirational they're people
who will just
do any they believe the ends justify the
means it's the whole sort of new left
the new left is not like your old
classical liberal who believed in the
process for its own sake
this new left believes the process is
ridiculous the process is solely there
to achieve a certain objective
and that's why they have no like
hypocrisy means nothing to them
unlike dante's you know bottom level of
hell they would you know in their level
of hell
hypocrisy takes you to heaven so it's a
whole different mindset and a lot of
them actually celebrate their misconduct
celebrate their malfeasance the written
house prosecutor is one of the most
unethical prosecutors i've ever
witnessed
you know you mentioned uh related to
defunding the police and how in kenosha
that just that we've seen this in so
many of these cities that they're just
the
law enforcement is not doing what it's
supposed to do as you know i'm still
here in crazy
la we've got a uh d.a
this guy george gascon bernie backed d.a
middle-aged white guy who got rid of our
first female black d.a not that i care
about that but i thought you know the
identity politics
people do in any event he is doing
exactly what he did in san francisco
before which is exactly what chessa
bodine is doing in san francisco now
where they are just choosing not to
prosecute
certain crimes now i'm not a legal
expert but this is at this point this is
seeming
criminal to me like when they when they
swear themselves or when they get sworn
in
it's to defend the laws and they're just
picking which laws they're not defending
do they need to be sued i mean there's
recalls in place but
is this not just like the most obvious
dereliction of duty
i think there should be more legal
remedies our current courts make it
almost impossible to ever sue
prosecutors
but it's like the texas sheriff suing
biden over refusal to enforce
immigration laws
the same thing because what they're
really doing is they're weaponizing a
criminal class it's kind of like early
1920s russia that the immediate the
initial stage of the soviet revolution
they often weaponized the criminal class
to side with them in the uh the ongoing
civil war that took place post 19 1917.
that's what they're kind of doing here
it's kind of what they did with the
black panthers in the late 60s early 70s
people don't know how much they were
embedded with drug dealers and criminal
operations
the thought process was this can be our
own political street army
allowing them to it sort of extend their
political power like it's
like escape from l.a might soon be a
documentary rather than just a film
but that's the name of my documentary
deservedly so i mean because this is
insane
what's taking place i mean when you when
people can't even go into a group why
would you even buy anything anymore
under
a thousand bucks you're walking in you
see somebody walk in steal a bunch of
stuff and walk right out
this is just insanity this but what does
it promote it promotes disrespect for
the law
what that produces is 1970s level crime
problems
and now politically that almost always
leads to a backlash
but in the interim a lot of
working-class people are the primary
people to suffer it's not the
west side beverly hills crowd that's
going to suffer it's the south central
and east l.a folks who are going to
suffer right so to be clear
right now in new york city because of
their ridiculous d.a you are allowed to
jump the turnstile so if you are
paying to get on the subway you're
basically a sucker we're saying hey
why are you paying just get on your good
high tops and jump that thing and then
here in la or san francisco
you are now allowed to trespass i think
it's 800
that you're allowed to steal from a
store so i always tell people you get a
playstation
5 with four games you can't get five
games then you're over the threshold
then you could be in trouble
but it's like you're encouraging people
to break the law basically
and i would have more respect for them
if they said we'll prosecute anybody who
steals less than 2 000
but let anybody off who steals more than
ten thousand because then they would be
down on rodeo drive but instead they're
basically asking like i have a a client
that's a
mexican american shop owner that owns a
little grocery stores
and throughout uh east l.a they're the
number ones who are
people victimized by this this doesn't
help working class people this
hurts working class honest people and
and rewards the criminal class
for the benefit of a political class and
that's why it's it's very dangerous but
it's politics is not even what they
pretended to be so what about
when we see democrats i mean i think
kamala harris actually
as a as a candidate it was before the
election had
taken place she was actually helping uh
fund some of these antifa people get out
of jail in minneapolis and some other
places
uh they are breaking the laws but for
some reason antifa is still on twitter
and everywhere else you know trump's
gone but they're everywhere
and that we actually have politicians
that are raising money
to help criminals that burn down stores
and you know attack cars on the street
uh to get out of jail yeah i mean it's
it's
extraordinary the last time we had
anything like this was late 1960s
when you had people in bed with the
black panthers in bed with actual
weather underground
in bed with a wide range of you know
there was like a different revolutionary
name every other week
people forget the crips you know
actually likes the committee for
revolution or whatever
i mean it was smart you're a local gang
and you're like oh we just rebrand
rebrand as political and now now we can
steal stuff and kill people and
everything's okay it's kosher
but that's the same we brought back that
mindset
it was a disaster last time i don't know
anybody believe it's going to be
anything other than a disaster this time
what kind of backlash do you think we're
going to see on this stuff
well if the 1970s or any preview you're
going to see dirty harry style backlash
you're going to see i mean like jd
vance's grandmother
her hero was dirty harry because of
growing up in that politically that's
why she had that 44
next door even when she couldn't
physically lift it you know later on in
life
so i think that's the kind of mindset
you're going to see you're going to see
more and more people
and i hope they don't go too far i hope
people were met you know civil rights
are important those are sometimes
violated by police actors
and sometimes in the 70s people were so
mad at the lawlessness
that they green lit some abusive
behaviors i think we need to find the
right balance in countering what's
taking place by the left currently do
you think it's possible that the cities
just
aren't going to work anymore like that
like new york city for example where i
lived for most of my adult life 20 years
i
loved loved loved loved new york city if
you can make it there you can make it
anywhere like
i think everyone until these last couple
years i would say that everyone in
america
should live there for a little while
just to get a taste of that thing but
the idea of being there now where at any
given moment
they can attack you on the street if
you're sitting at a restaurant or they
can break into the store
or hop the subway thing or the litany of
other things going on like
that maybe city life in a political
environment like this
just doesn't work well just look at my
client amy cooper
because the background you're describing
is the context they failed to include in
the media coverage
she's just out to help her dog run and
they'd shut down the dog runs in the
name of kovitz somehow
so the only place she could help get her
dog run to even get outside
during this lockdown era uh last summer
was
in the park and so she's by herself
early in the morning in the park
and then suddenly somebody jumps her
says that they got some you know little
treats for her dog
which would scare anybody particularly a
young single woman in a city
particularly in the environment of what
was happening in new york at the time
where crime was skyrocketing and
everything else
and she reacts by just wanting to call
police and then she's blamed
she's demonized she loses her job she
has to leave the country
she's blacklisted from employment and
originally she was criminally prosecuted
until i got the prosecutor to dismiss
all charges
that's reality of life in new york city
what went from being
a dream went for someone like her a
quiet
you know a you know kid on the spectrum
uh to being an utter nightmare right so
that case which we
we also covered that one i mean there's
video basically where she's telling the
guy to get away from her but of course
the media framed its surprise surprise
as if she's a white supremacist and this
nice black man just approached her
to play with the dog and everything else
now obviously some of that stuff will
work out but
when someone like her gets fired from
their job
from something like that what what is
the legal recourse that they have
because it had nothing to do with
anything she did
obviously at the office and completely
demonized i mean like this was someone
who was one of the most successful in
her business
sort of a math nerd kind of a quiet kid
from canada all of a sudden not only was
she fired summarily without any benefits
and without any severance
i lost all the benefits that she'd been
accruing she couldn't get a job anywhere
else in the industry
because her name is now radioactive
because of these media lies that have
been told about her
i mean i think it was cbs even rain with
a story saying she had been convicted
at one point it was like they give me
the case in it being she was not only
was it all dismissed it was dismissed
with prejudice
with no deal no diversion no nothing
this was an acknowledgement by the city
of new york
that they it was a complete mistake what
the allegations were against her
because the truth came out she had
talked to the cops at the scene
she had clarified everything without any
question or controversy
what they didn't know is that first time
when she's on the phone they couldn't
hear her the phone was breaking up which
if you understand that that's why she's
panicking she's like there's nobody
coming to rescue me
uh and as to your point is to that guy a
week before when he did the same thing
to an african-american man that may
almost beat him up i mean because i mean
that was that response but you know the
but it gives you a sense when you live
in that kind of environment where
overnight you can feel like you're in
kafka's the trial
then the the in the world in ripped
by crime and lockdowns you know new york
city looks like
escape from new york john carpenter
instead of new york of dreams you know
new york the big apple
new york you know sleepless in seattle
kind of new york right well that's also
the thing it's like
people were so hyper racialized right
now to think about race all the time to
realize that everyone's got a camera to
think
that someone's coming to get you because
you know crime is jumping that everyone
is a little bit jumpy but but for the
average person that sees that i think
what they think is
oh i'm never going to speak up about
anything because i don't want to lose my
job
what would you what advice would you
give to people relative to keeping their
jobs but still being able to speak up
because that's probably like the number
one question i get at this point i don't
want to lose my job
yeah you know what's interesting is you
know michael malus has a version of
curse them with your yes sirs
like figure out whatever their
conspiracy theories are about you and
play into them
right and then they'll be even more
terrified and whatnot so
there's a lot that's the old ralph
ellison phrase curse them with your yes
sirs from
invisible man so i think there's a i
think for each person
i don't impose on anybody an obligation
to be a hero you don't have to go out
and make a noble stand
if you feel like you're in a position
where you can then i encourage people to
do so
and lawyers like me will help bring
suits for them we're challenging mass
mandates we're challenging vaccine
mandates
we're challenging these unconstitutional
firings brought defamation claims from
everybody from the covington kids
to anybody that's been politically
targeted for the wrong purposes
currently suing don lemon over some of
his behavior
so not afraid there's lawyers out there
that will be willing to represent you
and justify your cause
but that doesn't mean you have to be a
hero do what makes the most sense for
you
and figure out the best way you can both
assert your independence
care about what you care about and still
protect what
matters most to you and sometimes that
means protect your job
are you worried that we're going to
become just like a society that
everything
ends up in the courts basically that you
know one side will you know the new york
times will call me a white supremacist
every other week
and that you know i'm sort of over it at
this point and i you know and i if
anything i use it as fuel
to keep attacking but you know that the
average person that's just sick of this
that we're going to start suing over
words
and you know libel and slander laws are
very very specific but that will just
end up in this place where it'll be less
and less people will say what they think
more and more lawsuits will be there
and the spirit of the first amendment
will just sort of crumble even if it's
not
legally demolished well that's where i
think that
the court of public opinion is critical
and how people support
independent technology platforms support
independent content creators
share those messages where and when they
feel comfortable you know look at the
resistance mechanisms that people have
employed
through every civil rights movement in
history and there have been successful
ways to push back
the whether it's civil rights for
african americans uh
or any other cause that the civil right
you'll find they often use like
people behind the iron curtain found
ways to communicate in secret found ways
to get out key messages
found ways to resist in ways little and
small and big
and sooner or later what people should
remember is the system can't the system
needs the whole four pillars of power
sit on the fifth pillar of power which
is the perception of the moral
legitimacy
of the other four take out that fifth
pillar of power and the whole system
crumbles
and people should remember their own
nobody can close big tech cannot shut
down
the archives of nature and the rights of
man and if we listen to our conscience
we can take action and that can still
change the world as it always has
ah barnes that should have been your
closing statement but i'm going i'm
going for one more here you're
definitely a lawyer that was a primo
closing statement
um i got one for you that you know i
listen to you and viva all the time and
you guys are awesome but i don't know
that i've heard you talk about this
specifically at
at what point well it's a two-parter at
what point do you think that
the the lefty democrats voted in i'm not
talking about the da's i'm talking about
aoc and ohan omar and rashida talib and
that whole crew
that are clearly undermining the values
of america
at what point do you think they're in
dereliction of their oath of office
which is to defend the constitution of
the united states because it seems to me
that they're treading as close as
possible
i get that it would be almost impossible
to prove but do you think there is
some sort of tipping point with that if
every message that you send out
is anti-american if you can't send out a
pro-cuba
demonstrator tweet i mean none of them
have because they're kind of into
communism
like at what point do you think there is
an actual
dereliction of what they've sworn to
protect
i see it as a two-fold thing whether or
not there's been a dereliction of their
duty and then who has remedy for that
dereliction of duty when it comes to
remedy i always favor elections wherever
possible
to having the people having control so
that uh but
that so in terms of remedy for their
dereliction of duty that's what i
believe the remedy is
but i believe without question they've
shown dereliction of duty
it's a version of confession through
projection take a lot of aoc's and other
people's statements about january 6th
and then change it from her saying ted
cruz did this or that person did this
to her admitting she did it related to
all the things that happened all summer
and then oh you she's actually just
confessing
that you know really this is a violation
of oath this is a violation of the
constitution this put people in danger
i really shouldn't be a congressman they
should lock me up all the things she's
saying about other people
are really confessions of what she's
done right so of course we'd rather this
go to the ballot box but at some point i
do sort of feel like they're going to do
something that will
push it to the other side but my other
question related to this is
um it seems to me you know i know i'm a
crazy right-wing conspiracy theorist but
it seems to me that something's not
quite right with joe biden
and it seems to me that pretty much
everyone knows it
and joe biden often slips up and says oh
i'm going to get in trouble for saying
this and the question
of course is well who's he going to get
in trouble with at what
point is that a legal issue that it
seems that
everyone around joe biden knows
something's not right with him
and what i keep saying is at some point
it's going to break something's going to
happen one of those moments that he
freezes into the camera
is going to go on for 20 seconds longer
than the 20 seconds it goes on now or
some other
something and suddenly when the dam
breaks
the rats are going to have to get off
that ship so fast and they're all going
to turn on each other everyone's going
to be like no no i was the one right i
was the one that wanted to wave
and tell everybody and tell the media
and all that stuff
and they will turn on each other like
could there end up being like a real
legal case related to all of that
well there is it's another case of
confession through projection because
you think about all the allegations
against trump
that there's family members involved in
corruption overseas
that it involved foreign illicit
interference in the election
and that the president is someone who's
mentally ill and should be removed for
25th amendment purposes
they basically were describing joe biden
and there's no ques that is what the
25th amendment is there for
i think the problem the political
democratic establishment has i think
they even thought about
using it at some point the problem is
kamala harris is so hated throughout the
country they don't have a popular
replacement
uh so i think that there's no question i
mean we have a live dementia candidate
that
people like putin get to make fun of on
a regular basis
i mean the north koreans are making fun
of us the north koreans this is not good
so this is the sign of where we're at
it's a sign of a declining empire
michael malus calls it a white pill
because he's like just look at it joe
biden is the head of the empire
how can you not feel optimistic for the
end of the empire so the
there's some truth to that uh but yeah
no the 25th amendment is there for
people like joe biden who are clearly
constitutionally cognitively incapable
of exercising the duties of their office
barnes i look forward to continuing this
adventure with you
we got a lot of we got a lot of work to
do right i always end my show these days
by saying you know
we got work to do and i got nothing
better to do than save the world
exactly the way i see it as i tell
people it's like paul revere we're in
his little uh
silversmith shop back in the 1760s
and the world might look like doom and
gloom but within a generation we had the
greatest revolution the world had ever
seen
robert barnes i thank you my friend glad
to be here if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversation about
law instead of the non-stop yelling you
get everywhere else check out our law
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell